so guys as promised I am back reviewing
the next film in my series of reviews
leading up to David Fincher's gone girl
this October and that review is for the
game starring Michael Douglas I
apologize that my reviews came out a
little bit slower this weekend they're
going to be a little bit slower this
week as well because I'm actually
currently in LA as you watch this I'm
going to be visiting the schmoes no
podcast I'm doing something with screen
junkies it's gonna be a lot of fun and
I'm looking forward to you guys checking
out those podcasts that I go on with me
but let's talk about the game I own The
Criterion blu-ray out of this movie and
that's because I do like this movie a
lot despite the fact that there are some
issues with the film it's not David
Fincher's best movie but it is a very
very well directed thriller and one of
Michael Douglas's best performances one
of the things that David Fincher did
really well in this movie was build a
continuing sense of dread and that's
something he did excellently with seven
and with this film he was still really
in tune with that because as the film
progresses it starts off and you feel
like there's something off you there's
something wrong you just sense that
something isn't entirely right and a lot
of that is due to Michael Douglas's
performance because he is very
captivating in this movie he plays an
a-hole he's a businessman he's rude to
everyone he's rude to his family
no one likes this guy and his brother
played by Sean Penn offers him a gift
it's this life changing he calls it
thing called CRS it's a company that he
says makes your life fun and once he
eventually accepts the terms and
conditions nowadays you just check a
little box online that says you did that
even though he didn't read anything his
life turns into a living hell everything
around him crumbles he's running for his
life
he has no idea what's going on I've seen
this movie multiple times and for a
large portion of it I am absolutely
captivated this is a brilliant looking
movie David Fincher once again is
meticulous with his direction every shot
in this film looks like it's been
planned and re shot multiple times until
it was absolutely perfect from 7 and
onward it is very difficult to find a
technical flaw in a David Fincher film
because this guy makes everything look
immaculate and as I said Michael Douglas
is fantastic in this movie the
performances our top-notch Sean Penn is
also really good despite his limited
screen time my issue with the game is it
and in fact David Fincher has the same
issue he's recently been quoted as
saying that he may not have been the
right director for the game and that he
didn't feel like he got everything right
in the final act and actually really
respect him for admitting them because
that's what I've been thinking since the
first time I saw the game I find the
ending very far-fetched I find it very
convenient I feel like it just doesn't
make the rest of the film work as well
as it should
despite that ending that I don't really
enjoy everything else that came before
it I found absolutely enthralling but
the film just has such a good hold on
its suspense for a very long time and I
really like the backstory of Michael
Douglas's character with his father and
the way that Fincher used old filmmaking
to show flashback sequences was also
original because that's something that
isn't very original in screenplays
nowadays is the flashback scene where
you learn things and okay it's a
flashback but the way that Fincher did
it with that old style of filmmaking
made it more unique and I appreciated it
a lot more and also stuck in my head a
lot more than your average flashback
sequence would so Michael Douglas is
fantastic in this movie it's one of his
best performances the movie looks
amazing and for a large portion of the
movie it's suspenseful its captivating
its mesmerizing it's just at the end
makes everything else that happened
before it not really makes sense keep
your eye open for an incredible taxi cab
sequence with amazing camerawork and I
think it's probably the most intense
I've ever seen Michael Douglas in a
scene I'm gonna give the game a B+ I do
think it is worth your time I do think
it is a good Fincher movie it's just
that the ending doesn't really work for
me
so guys like I said I am in LA right now
I'm going to be visiting the schmoes no
podcast I'm gonna be going on there
other podcasts as well like profiles
GUILTY movie pleasures Jedi Alliance and
meet the movie pres and I'm gonna be
doing something special with screen
junkies stay tuned for that I'm really
excited about that guys also something
I'm really excited about is this video
actually as a sponsor I was contacted by
naturebox which is this really great
company that sends you a box once a
month of really awesome healthy foods
that you can eat and eating is awesome
and they sent me one filled with really
awesome stuff this is really healthy
food no trans fats no disgusting oils or
anything that you don't want to take
into your body and through the length
that I have included in this
subscription you can get one
for free as a free trial they're doing
this they can reach more people I like
my pizza I like my tacos but every once
in a while it's really cool to get some
french toast granola or some strawberry
fig bars which I ordered came to my
house and are delicious by the way
I'm not just being like wow those guys
in a commercial like oh so good it's not
good like this is really frickin good
man so like I said check out the link in
my subscription for a free trial to
naturebox and if you don't like it you
can cancel anytime and that's cool with
them - thank you so much naturebox for
contacting me I still got honey dijon
pretzels in my mouth guys when I'm in LA
I'm gonna try to see the guest and two
faces of January I'm not sure because
I'm gonna be so busy but I definitely
want to see the guests because it's not
playing in Ohio anywhere and I want to
get a review for that to you guys
stay tuned for my reviews of Fight Club
and every other Fincher film leading up
to GaN girl which I'm really excited to
give you guys coming early in October
thank you so much as always for watching
guys and I also want to say to my wife I
love you this is my first review as a
married man thank you very much for
putting up with my stupidity have a
great day guys and if you like this you
can click right here and get stockman
eyes